hey guys it is the 27th of October today
which is about the time to give up on
your cool Halloween idea and just go
with whatever you can scrape together in
time I'm just peace and using this up
some free stuff for your weekend but
Lance the handsome collection is
currently free on the Xbox store until
October 30 and Microsoft have also
confirmed Xbox Live members will be able
to play multiplayer games across xbox
one and 360 until October 30 without an
xbox live gold subscription Microsoft
have said this is a great opportunity
for place across both consoles to
experience one of the most popular
benefits of xbox live gold membership
when it comes to multiplayer gaming
network reliability is everything login
now to play on a network that delivers
as well as you do next up titanfall 2
will not have a season pass and develop
a respawn have had quite a bit to say
about it too as announced previously all
titanfall to post launch maps and modes
will be free respawn tweeted remember
when buying a game got you everything
seemingly not fans of the recent trend
of season pass add-ons respawn explained
once you've purchased titanfall to your
investments includes a full
single-player campaign the full
multiplayer maps and modes and long-term
support with no hidden costs respawn of
said they want all players to have
access to the same content so is not to
split up the audience titanfall tues
drew out tomorrow one ps4 xbox one and
pc finally more nintendo switch news or
perhaps a lack thereof has arrived
nintendo officially announced that they
will be revealing the consoles price
game lineup system specs and other
details and a presentation scheduled for
january 12 nintendo president tatsumi
kimishima also teased that there will be
hardware add-ons and accessories for
switch he explained that there is more
in store than what was revealed in last
week's announcement video hopping over
to the last official side of the fence
sources familiar with the console have
told Eurogamer that switch is equipped
with a 6.2 inch screen featuring a 720p
resolution reportedly the console also
features a capacitive
t touch screen at which the 30s and we
you did not feature that is everything
I've got for you today to let me know
what you cared about in that comment
section head to gamespot for stories on
monster hunter and watch dogs too and
the US will be showing you their
Halloween costumes tomorrow so i will
see you again later